[Music]
alright guys we are back for our second
lecture Thursday evening and this is a
team of the week we don't have any huge
tournaments going on right now but I
found one game from one of the big
tournaments going on right now I'll
flood open in Russia so and it's my
specialty
game it's my specialty this opening Slav
exchange so I can show you this game ok
d4 Knight f6 c4 c6 okay so it's it's
gonna be a Slav defense transposition
here okay so now I go here Knight c3 d5
I take take Bishop f4 knight c6
III
so the Slav defense exchange slab is a
Slav defense exchange variation okay now
he goes here Bishop f5 now you play
Queen b3 activating on B server and
activating on d5 now go see you tonight
a5 attack in the queen
now Queen a4 check Bishop d7
and now Bishop d7 you have to improve
your queen now queen is attacked yes oh
this oh this is the game against our
vinda or vinda against iguras aravinda
see guru of indian grandmaster and Rina
against Russian masu do so so this is
all theory played III Knight f3 knight
each five fish should be 596 a tree
because the point of a tree is you know
if you go Bishop the tree you're gonna
be hit by a night before fork so it's
not gonna be very good so that's why
you're trying to do that play a tree
you're trying to play a tree to prevent
any night before jumps Bishop e7 Bishop
d3 again I really like these positions
for why because you know I I think it's
symmetrical but I think white office has
a little little bit lettuce something a
little extra enough in this positions so
he took now now first pause in a game
here how you're going to capture here
the first pause of the game now what are
you gonna do
[Music]
well you have a choice
I mean you had to make a decision here
you take what the party with a night but
you're doubling the pawns you know and
that's a drawback you know
yeah that's why we take back with a
knight now he goes here Knight f6 f4 I
like this for white even though you lost
the bishop now you have a very strong
night he goes g6 she for look at that
aggression by young Indian Grandmaster
Orinda yeah for example if black tries
to go here H fire it's a really bad move
why what's the move the rush what's the
move here
what is the tactic how are you going to
justify this
yeah this trip takes two six he takes to
six Queen takes to six and Queen f7 mate
so now what to do after this
yeah
Castle okay so what are you suggesting
well yeah we play Bishop c6 yeah
and now white plays G for age 497
[Music]
this is bambam
now
933 back keeping the night for now okay
I go see rg5 fixing it and now treating
some potential age five ideas the
character of the position is closed so
it's not that necessary to Castle so
Bishop d6 h5 putting pressure on g6 rook
g8 t2
connecting the rooks a3 the white is
better white is for choice here for sure
white is for choice because you a lot
more active here but now he takes rook
h6 doubling up doubling up the rooks
Queen d7 I go screaming he's eyeballing
eyeballing b7 here okay
he's eyeballing a little bit here he's
trying to induce he's trying to induce
some pump pushes or something like that
okay
so that's what he's trying to trying to
induce induce some pawn pushes so I go a
skink here 91 King c7 now look at the
night goal now I have to look forces
take and now he wants to bring the
Knight to g4 Queen c2 ah look at those
Knights
they're wonderful okay so the space
block is very very much squeezed here
okay
and those Knights are giving some nice
space okay for the pieces they're giving
some nice space now he goes here
black is trying to hang on he cannot
just move the king away because then
there's a bishop eight-six tactic if you
capture you lose the bishop but not so
simple still and our block is increasing
the pressure bank before getting some
more space on the other side of the
world really
it's amazing how how white is grabbing
all the space you know very very nice
game played by young indian grandmaster
here he is pressuring king b6 and now
what do you I play here this King b6
okay it looks a little bit different now
what should white do here now we know as
we say white is for choice here but what
to do white is for choice but what to do
the target at 90 in which can usually
hit the c6 quad he might take the night
we got to pieces
you know who the Queen over to be to
this we should be part and not drop the
a3
what did he play here also for our
YouTube audience
what should wide to here of course some
of you might have seen this game and
what should really white do in his
position to proceed here to proceed here
absolutely Knight f3 to e5 centralizing
it ok now he takes now don't rush very
important check needed here very
important check needed here what do you
do correct
now he takes check with a pawn
now he goes here
whoa you take them you take the night II
can't take back because we dropped the
visa comes up he drops the pawn now he
takes now he's ready to put that knight
on f6 I mean this is some serious
squeeze right here now I was here and
look at that boom King comes in you're
not afraid of d4 because d4 check you
have bishop e4 Knight f6 actually it's
very important to play this right away
because if you think you're gonna get
this in it's a problem he goes here and
here he is no longer taking your knight
this is just yeah you had to do it
immediately which he did but now black
plays d5 because otherwise this is just
just it's just the game over look at
that so he goes here now what you should
do
efore is threatened here if or is
threatened what to do now
I would this will be king over the t3
comes in when he comes in and I can work
the King up through the docks for us so
what do you do
well you don't want to allow him before
that's the thing you don't want to
that's what he did
now if he takes you take with the bishop
you're better if he plays d4 you have
Bishop c4 so if he goes here right
you're actually gonna win because you
attack here and then you go here okay
you cannot move in then you can bring
the king and play for p5 okay so he
takes I take sorry
they take white takes Nautica faith and
now modulus check
defend now panopter should be no problem
now Lukas coming in and training the
rocks and rook is coming in to his
seventh so black resigned here because
if he takes King takes something like
this yeah I'm just gonna break
well now I want a quince I have to go
here and just take
and just just a simple demonstration of
Magadh echo here still maybe it's gonna
come here and you push the pump into
Quinn
very very very impressive way in my
opinion let's go back again and see the
opening play by Grandma Sabine de it's
very impressive I mean not often and he
was playing somebody much higher rank
than him
you know maybe about 50 60 points higher
than him so so but again sloth defends
after six black is hinting that he's
gonna play the sloth and very direct
very direct and very simple plague and a
tree to stop all the night before Bishop
d3 takes Knight takes and now f4 and I
like this G 4h for aggression you know
grabbing space and attend it was just it
was so nice the space advantage in
particular this moment this is this is a
very high class maneuver 91 not often
you see this look at this maneuver bring
in the nitrogen for very very high level
of play I really like this game I mean
this is this is already a very difficult
position for black yeah
it's it's very very passive okay alright
we're gonna do a couple of hard
positions now okay so our YouTube
audience should get ready the previous
lecture was a medium difficulty now
we're gonna go to the hard section okay
these are all practical games so our
students as well at the Chess Club
should be ready all right gonna do a
couple of those hard ones okay
okay
white to play and win okay I'll try to
find one so you don't feel like
so you don't feel like it's always one
side is winning okay ready
it's white actually sorry all right
hard section for the YouTube as well
it's a 2016 game between Jordan one
forest and Benjamin Bach to young
grandmaster from the netherlands so
Benjamin book actually lives in st.
Louis he goes to st. Louis University
so Jordan one forest just had a
fantastic week on the tournament where
he had really really nice performance so
white block to play and a white to play
and win so I'm gonna give you some time
to think same for our audience so you
have some time to think and then you can
find the idea
Bock has two bishops and he probably was
counting on having having the nice
position
you gotta calculate yeah you got a you
got a calculate for sure here
that's what
because my brother King
then he go back in the corner
thank you maybe the Queen could hitting
me you can just push the pause it's like
it's more complicated
[Music]
if he comes back
Ben so in the chair we have a line here
from Mario and this is not computer
lines right make sure no computer usage
huh for anybody no computer usage have
to find your own yeah yeah okay King
takes King h8 Queen h6
and then Brooke discovered check I'm
sorry takes Queen h6 Bravo Bravo bravo
Bravo Bravo but there is another line in
this one
rook g7 takes rook g1 check King h8 rook
g5 hitting the Queen the Queen goes back
there is a discover idea here so he
sacked the rule and you pick it up you
set the rook and you pick it up okay
but there is a little problem there's a
little issue accession issue --is he
goes here now King f6 what do you do now
question remaining the question is
remaining what do you do now then do
they have that line that's the question
to have a complete solution you must
have this line as well to have the
complete solution
five
sorry where
change sound back not so simple not as
simple as it appears to be it may appear
simple but it not as appears to be
correct correct
yes II five and that wins it because he
has to take it
twin takes here
I can also consider this idea 94/95 and
they're not even mentioning that they
mentioned that this is just he resigned
actually after a five check he resigned
well all its winning actually I'll maybe
resigned not but yeah this seems very
very close yeah 94 with idea I think
this pretty much curtains mm-hmm
because if you take I can check and win
this you know I don't see how you're
gonna stop night at five check and that
just wins your Quinn there might be
other ways to do it okay there might be
other ways to dividing us this if I was
a very strong idea so that's how you
Orton run Forrest you know not sure if
it yeah he played this actually yeah
we're not to get a winning position I
don't know whether or not he converted
but he got a winning position you still
have to win it you still have to win it
but that's you know you got at least all
right
this position is again between two
strong grandmasters Roy taschek Hari
Krishna
we're taschek is white from Poland
this is gonna be on a YouTube channel
some coaches have YouTube channel so
yeah this will be uploaded and next day
or two
bye consignment here and immediately
immediately you go home you go home you
can watch this one more time okay well
there we go
that's thanks to Ben Simon it will be
done the new technology we don't have to
wait anymore
alright then everybody know Ben I mean
although our YouTube channel knows the
Ben man is the master all right white to
play and win now let's make you guys a
masters in the game of chess how are we
gonna do this we have four
how's our YouTube are we active on
YouTube Ben we're very active all the
YouTube guys I appreciate your comments
a lot of people leave comments on my
videos appreciate that I'm reading it so
make sure you subscribe there and
comment if your thoughts I need you to
play like Grandmaster houet a sec how we
gonna do that how we gonna play like boy
taschek here
I'm just thinking a crazy
because their part is build up some king
is in economy you're okay you're okay
yeah
all right well let's give you a couple
of more minutes to think
where's the Queen no custody Queenie
Mikey look Mikey game time attacking the
Queen she goes down one far
what's the plan here what's the idea
what's the plan here what is the idea
maybe maybe maybe
so okay after you would knows these
things
then you push well let's let's calculate
concrete lines yeah concrete move by
move so what's the I make this move what
is he gonna do concrete stuff where we
have concrete okay and but I mean I'm
not sure if we have such a devastating
attack there you know I mean we're
moving the Queen back which I understand
it's good but I'm gonna give you a
little hint okay let's find a better
version of that move let's find a better
version of that move can we do that can
you do that for me
find a better version of that same same
move
I bet it might go to CC coming back to
the focus focus you don't want to just
drop anything okay
there is no reason dropping anything
here
you actually made a mistake
he found the first move but the second
move he found he played the inaccurate
move and let his opponent get back into
the game are you gonna be you not gonna
play that inaccurate move of course not
you guys not the students at the st.
Louis chess club they're gonna play
stronger than we taschek 2727 rating got
some strong guys in audience today live
audience
I'm sure the YouTube audience is very
strong as well with players all over the
world and all over USA Ben has the
activity on the YouTube that is the
cancer that is the solution Ben bravo
Bravo YouTube audience check check well
did you say the moves like you guys say
a lot of things I don't know so check
wins the Quinn ok discovery discovery
check did you say that well but that's I
know but if I take your rook yeah that's
the hole so he has to go here and now
this is the idea thank you very much
okay guess what
Grandmaster boy taschek mistis heap sack
tonight and went for this move thinking
it's the same thing but now strong
unexpected move is out there strong
unexpected move is out there waiting
absolutely yes and now he takes the
Queen we take this and it's just uh it's
a very messy position okay I should
actually this black winces probably so I
don't know what happened the rest of the
game but it was just some complications
okay
x-ray attack yes all right well done
okay well done for finding the defense
this rookie eight resource okay okay
yeah of course they're harder yeah of
course 27:15 might not be that much but
hundred that's already very serious yeah
it means the other guy is just stronger
player opening wise and everything I
mean again 2600 can still beat him but
in a long-distance 2,700 player is just
a stronger player but on a short
distance anything can happen okay you
could have you know 2600 beater 2800
which happens no in regular Chester all
right black to play and win
sorry about that my two plays correct
it's white to play yes
white to play and win this game is play
bit win vojta shake even shook
yeah but luckily he lost his counseling
privileges masters castling privileges
the two bishops in monkey gang to
blanket the bishop priority Internet is
powerful
[Music]
well yeah that's that's a normal move
but we need you to do something special
something extraordinary
exactly I want something extraordinary
extra I want something extra ordinary
nothing ordinary here okay
okay what's your suggestion Knight b6
Bravo now if he takes you gonna take the
queen with a mate so he has to take you
take he takes that is Bravo's los Bravos
wow that is a grand master move right
there Knight b6 Bravo the student from
the live audience class fun anybody in
the chat found a move anybody from all
the people watching in the world
anybody goodness strong strong presence
we have from the locals chess players
strong present guys I'm gonna sit at the
next position it's gonna be the last one
for tonight okay it's gonna be hard one
the hardest one okay are you ready
yeah strong representation today like to
play know why to playing draw I know I
know I know
all right all right all right how are we
doing here
wide to play and draw white to play and
draw and I need you to play
extraordinary of course of course you
have to play extraordinarily six move
calculation I want no moving six move
calculation also the players on YouTube
six move calculation before you throw
out or you cannot run answer gotta have
all six months at least five minimum
minimum okay this is a game of vladislav
art EMF against Graham a static RAM
Petrosyan artemyev Pedro Sheehan
artemiev Bedrosian
oh yeah kinda mics there so we can just
keep chicken
you must shine here's to find this
solution it's not your regular it's a
extraordinary one shine let's go Bishop
capture
[Music]
haiii once again once again strong
representation from the live audience
and if I go back if I go back if I go
back what do you do go check check check
check
Wow very nice very very nice work how
did you see all that explain your
thinking process to our audience how did
you see all that decoy decoy sacrificing
decoy Bravo and then you did more decoys
do you realize they're more decoys here
that's a decoy and now that decoy we
have here and deflection of sacrifice
okay well done well done guys thank you
everybody for attending the class we'll
be here next Thursday okay next Thursday
and we're gonna talk about more live
games and also some more grandmasters
choice games we'll have okay excellent
job see you
you
[Music]